welcome back to a20 special relativity
let's start here with a short summary we
have seen through experimental
measurements that there is no ether
that electromagnetic waves travel
through vacuum
we have discussed the concept of
relative
of the relativity of simultaneity
meaning that
two events might occur simultaneous to
one reference in one reference frame to
one observer where they are not to
another
in the last two videos we looked at
clocks and we've seen that moving clocks
run slow we've always also seen that
moving objects appear
smaller their length contract
we found
that
the time of a moving clock
is related to the time in the clock at
rest is a gamma factor because it's time
dilation
and for the length we have seen that
there is a one over gamma dependency
length contraction
the entire discussion was based on
einstein's prostitutes we simply used
einstein's postulates and then we looked
at experiments of clocks
now you might argue that the setup of
the clock is actually what's tricking us
here but i can tell you that is not the
case as you have seen for the mirror and
the mirror doesn't know about optical
clocks it just decays based on its own
properties
i think it's fair to say that ponca
and lorenz came to similar conclusions
about the same time as einstein did
delta t at rest and delta l addressed
the time and the length are also
sometimes called the proper time and
length
in german and i actually prefer this a
bit uh we use the word eigen which means
own so it's basically the time the own
time of the object the object of being
at rest
so we can now ask what are you know i've
seen time is
suspect what is not suspect what are the
uh observables which are invariant and
by by this i mean the observables and we
have two different reference frame and
we have a conversation we do actually
agree
in a conversation about
an observation we have
we have seen we cannot agree on time and
we cannot agree on on the length in the
direction in which we are moving
so can i ask for example what happens to
the width of the height
we put a train on a train track and it's
fast moving
is that constructed or even expanded or
changing at all the answer is no
similarly i put a train track on a track
and i go very fast into a tunnel
that's the height of the tunnel change
also here the answer is no
and we can
verify this later
quantitatively
in summary transverse dimensions are not
affected they are not suspect we can
agree in a conversation of two people in
different reference frames
about the height and the width of a
train
that's good but what else is invariant
so here i want you to consider the time
and distance between two events or maybe
even three events observed from
different reference frames
and we introduce or reintroduce our
characters alice and bob and add carol
to this so we're going to have three
reference frames of three observers in
this in this discussion
so i want you to look at this one so
assume that
bob has a clock and it's moving with a
velocity v
and alec alice is observing bob's clock
we have done this before now we want to
also add carol to this and carol is
moving the 3 times the velocity
and is also observing bob's clock
what i want you to do
is look at this
property here so we have seen that the
height
is invariant so let's look at what
happens if i calculate two times the
height squared and i use
x and t time and space in order to
express the height
all right again this is an opportunity
to stop the
the clock stops the video and
works this out on a piece of paper
so
it turns out it's not that hard um
basically find that four times the
height squared is equal to
maybe it's hard
c squared times t squared minus x
squared
and since the height
is an invariant this property
c square the speed of light squared
times the time square minus x squared
is invariant so we can you know think
about them as delta t and delta x we
look at the
difference in time and the different in
space between two events
yeah
professor kluter entered the class and
at the other end of the class professor
pluta exploded
if i do the delta t and the delta x
between the two we square them and
subtract them
that is an observation we can all agree
on whether or not you're stationary in
the classroom or you're passing by
really quickly with your spacecraft
that observation is something we can
agree on and it's invariant this in this
this property is called the invariant
interval
you